whatever you want to give I had this
blog post I used to try to blog about
business back in the day and when we
were doing our very first startup right
out of college and none of my posters
got read by anybody nobody cared but one
post went semi viral and it was called
the first curse advantage and basically
I was saying how in a meeting the first
person who who uses a curse word sort of
establishes himself as the person who
just doesn't give a about the there
they put themselves in a position of
power and it also builds a different
level of rapport because you're
obviously using informal language with
somebody else and you're demonstrating
that you're not seeking their approval
in a way and so I always in meetings I
do this I try to be the first to curse
in a meeting what can I say I don't love
that and I'm like because you don't like
cursing in general I mean I actually
when I hear myself curse I'm like a man
I sound kind of trashy I agree I don't
like when I hear myself do it and I
think I'd do it too much but I've
noticed in meetings it changes the
dynamic like instantly and for better
for worse but I've but I think the
difference between being crude and
freeing cursing actually so like saying
I hate right my god you
see that so I don't like when people say
that quick quick story before we get
into this I went I got married in
September yeah and I had to go I got a
merry Catholic Church and you gotta go
meet with the priest ahead of time and I
was really nervous cuz I don't I don't
I'm not practicing I don't go to church
and but I wanted I the whole wedding was
they have to approve it and the whole
wedding was on the line right so I had
to like be a good Catholic and or at
least appear like one and I remember I
was sitting there and the guy was asking
the priest was asking me and my wife my
future wife about like so do you guys
agree on children what do you think
about birth control all this stuff or
whatever he's asking and I would just
say whatever I thought had to be so
right and I was very nervous I was like
yes sir yes we go to church like I just
said all everything and then my phone
rings and I was so nervous I go I go oh
sorry
really loud and then he looked at me it
was like my bad I didn't because
and I
I was so embarrassed that's amazing
yeah but he let it go he let it go good
guy yeah he let it go I thought I made a
joke about how I was asked him what
school he went to and he said he had
lost student debt and he said he's like
yeah but there's a young guy young like
in his 30s maybe late thirties and he
said but the church pays for it and I
made like a joke like ah so that's why
you joined and you didn't appreciate
that he didn't like that
[Music]